right before he's about to kill baby
Hitler boom tilda swinton the ancient
one shows up deadpool goes on a journey
kind of fixing all the plot holes and
like mistakes made throughout the MCU
he's hired to kill all of the spider-man
throughout the multiverses deadpool will
be introduced into this universe in an
attempt to kill smart-home
[Music]
rock stars this is rogue theory I'm Erik
Voss filling in for Philip this week as
he hustles I guess to UM keep us all
from starving god bless don't worry
everything's fine
but he's just an angel and a saint and
we appreciate him but as I take over for
o'cleary this week Deadpool is about to
take over them see you folks and go and
rogue with me on Deadpool remotely is
Tommy Bechtold
yeah yeah that's the sound he makes we
also got Danielle's speech so here with
us welcome back to the show I'm sorry I
still don't have my Wednesday Addams
outfit that's a deep cut for the
lifelong very okay go back to like mid
November episode yes yeah or why not
watch all of our episodes of rogue
theory on repeat watch them over and
over again
we won't mind and yes we also have
off-screen producer Zach Huddleston with
us as well salutations friends I really
introduced myself as the formulas hey
you know here at rogue theory we don't
discriminate against Prince tommy's or
poppers Tommy so we're gonna altogether
go rogue on Deadpool here's the deal
folks we know that Kevin Feige and the
higher-ups at Disney like Bob Iger who's
back in control the studio they're all
very
interested in a Deadpool MCU film
they're also willing to keep it r-rated
some recent rumors are suggesting that
Marvel might soft reboot the character
with like a new Wade Wilson
those aren't confirmed yet so in this
meantime as we're all waiting to find
out what happens I want you three to
pitch me the best way that Marvel can
introduce Deadpool into the MCU and let
me just say everyone is sounding crystal
clear of my new headphones sent to me by
my friend mark ended bills mafia thank
you Mark you are the man anyway moving
forward Deadpool how are you going to
get into the universe well he's got to
fight a big guy a Jolly Green Giant if
you will Deadpool will be introduced
into this universe in an attempt to kill
smart Hulk now oh well he kills smart
Hulk let me get there okay
Hulk cannot be killed Deadpool
regenerates I mean okay I mean they
think they've figured out a couple ways
to kill him in some offshoot comics but
Deadpool regenerates I mean they tried
really hard a Deadpool to to kill him he
really wanted to die and it didn't
happen so I think we're gonna have the
leader Tim Blake Nelson character from
from the credible Hulk he's going to
hire Wade Wilson aka Deadpool to kill
smart Hulk and they're gonna fight and a
lot of stuff is gonna get damaged and a
lot of stuff is gonna get broken
and a lot of quippy one-liners and a lot
of like almost what was there like Vin
Diesel from Fast & Furious
or or dave bautista from guardians level
hulk comebacks that Icarus groans and
like very simple like completions of the
joke punchlines are gonna happen but
eventually they're gonna realize that
they are being manipulated or dead
weight is gonna realize he's being
manipulated that the Hulk is not the
threat that he thinks he is and then
they've got a team out and it's gonna be
just like you know a knock them out
shooting down bad guys faster theory
style team-up buddy movie that will
treat both audiences and the filmmakers
to a delightful two-hour romp I estimate
making 700 million in the box office I
do that's exactly what the world
is missing right now another fast and
furious movie she were promised one the
cherry on the top of this Sunday is that
when they finally do realize that
they're meant to be on the same side
Deadpool joins The Avengers thus leaving
him into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as one of those like we can pull you in
when we need your help all our
spider-man in Captain America Civil War
Tommy I don't have our supply of rogue
ease on my end those are important ting
with Philip but what I do have are
Sparkle buck row bees have the currency
exchange value of one to one so I'm
gonna award you just for comparing your
pitch to anything past imperious related
you got me on board already take my
money for Deathly Hallows we've seen
definitely Hallows then you know if you
have it now you do know there's no point
in watching it I love that movie I even
if that's not Deadpool's introduction to
the MCU they need to make that happen at
some point and phase four I think it
will take the fun of Thor Ragnarok when
Thor and Hulk are fighting and multiply
it by four or five we've kind of we've
seen a variation of this with Deadpool
teaming up with Colossus right like he
works well with a big strong guy right
yeah who's not as verbose is there all
right who's next uh well I think that
Deadpool the only way they can really
justify it as if they kind of weave in
the multiverse spider-man you know what
I mean
just because he doesn't he hasn't
existed
the only way they can make it make sense
if I mean sure everyone will buy and if
they just like in like enters into the
universe because now he's bought but it
would be really cool if he's out hired
to kill all of the spider-man throughout
the multiverse is then he has a little
soft spot for Miles Morales cuz who
doesn't you know I love it so Deadpool
is entering the spider-verse
side of the multiverse pacifically okay
specifically yeah cute little Miles
Morales I mean I could see him in
Deadpool having like a very hip fun I
[Laughter]
really don't buy that they're gonna let
it be r-rated I mean this Disney we're
talking about and they may say that
they're gonna let it be r-rated but when
was the last time just needed an r-rated
movie they don't and they even they even
digitally covered up Daryl Hannah's butt
from splash when they put that flush
what's the Dodge not a name Raiden are
different and just real quick Danielle
are you saying the Deadpool is gonna
show up animated or you that Miles
Morales is gonna show up
live-action funny you say that last time
I was on the show I said that I really
wanted there to be a Roger Rabbit style
spider-verse next spider-man movie so
maybe this is it maybe there's a little
cartoon human action going on
you know cartoon on human Tommy loves
cartoon human action Daniel I think
that's a great idea I think definitely
pairing up Wade Wilson with Peter Parker
I mean Deadpool started in a way a kind
of parody like an adult version of a the
spider-man character his costume was
inspired by spider-man's just like what
a Spiderman was like a real [ __ ]
was profane and meta even more meta than
he is so yeah I think those two need to
be in a movie together and I hope that
at some point Disney can just like buy
all of Sony's spider-man properties so
that we don't do like think about what
kind of weird arrangements they would
need to make that happen who would be
like behind it like does a Wade Wilson
have an axe to grind against the
spider-man's is that out of jealousy or
is he like hired because it is hired you
know he's like give no shit's kind of
guy and I feel like he's just he's like
a hitman kind of in my like he he teams
up with sort of I mean I like the idea
this is also I mean this is like a
little bonus idea I guess I like the
idea of him being teaming up with like
the people who didn't make the x-men the
x-force the whispers of the x-force
because they're kind of like the the
like not cool kids the ones that weren't
cool enough to make it in you know what
I mean yeah I love that I love bringing
in some of these leftover Pete because
we're supposed to get an x-force movie I
think Drew Goddard was gonna direct it
and then you know Disney bought out all
the Fox's stuff so that got shelved so
to bring in that piece of it and to put
spider-man in a movie with Deadpool
you're getting to Sparkle but that's so
lucky because mine turned into gloves
and what's good one without another one
you know yeah you need two gloves
because you're gonna grab some of them
with the wrong hand and the wrong thing
with the wrong hand
Zach hit us with your theory okay here's
here's my theory and I think it's kind
of like Deadpool works his way into the
MCU by going meta right and so okay you
know the first Deadpool movie was kind
of like a meta commentary on superhero
movies the second Deadpool movie was
kind of a meta commentary on sequels
right and kind of the tropes and traps
of being in a sequel so I think this is
gonna kind of be a meta commentary on
like broad cinematic universes right so
as Deadpool comes into the MCU he
comments on the MCU and so Deadpool 2
ended with him kind of doing all the
time-travel you know killing himself
before he did Green Lantern or yeah I'm
Green Lantern and killing himself before
the bad Deadpool version and Wolverine
Origins so I think
like that continues right before he's
about to kill baby Hitler boom Tilda
Swinton the ancient one shows up okay I
was like oh wait Wilson there are some
other problems we need you to correct
right and then Deadpool goes on a
journey kind of fixing all the plot
holes and like mistakes made throughout
the MCU right so like you know going
back and like all the word retcons that
the MCU has had to do like oh that was
an infinity stone the whole time or like
no you know dig nor this version of
time-travel because we got this version
the time-travel or all of that like he
can go in wing to the audience right the
whole time he's not only like fixing
these problems in the MCU he's also like
inserting himself in the MCU right like
you go to the background of like um you
know the New York battle from Avengers 1
and like you pan down to the street and
like you know Deadpool is trying to
finish his Monte Cristo sandwich or
whatever he literally can be
it's like he's physically retconning
himself into the MC I love it I do love
that it reminds me of like what I loved
avengers endgame obviously but like they
feel like the second act of that movie
could have blown out the world of the
past MCU even more than they did I get
it it needs to be more than just a time
travel movie but like this kind of
sounds like exactly what like the fanboy
need wanted of enters in game 2 entirely
be just like Back to the Future 2 style
thing for three hours yeah and and you
could see like you've covered a lot Eric
that like Marvel's gonna be playing more
with this time-travel stuff with the
Loki series and like obviously we're
getting into the multiverse it's also
like it's such a thing in comics for
them to have like meta kind of comics
right like the whole like spider-ham
universe and like that you know like is
Marvel got to a place where it's very
kind of commenting on itself constantly
and that's kind of like the fun of
Deadpool IV comments on the tropes of
superhero movies and like just totally
lets you do that right like and you can
get
Robert Downey jr. cameo which is yes I
mean it's great and even if they can't
get the actors themselves they have so
much footage from like Lola VFX where
they can just like drag and drop them in
there drag and drop them in there they
get body doubles to stand in like they
can kind of fight you just make an
entire movie based off of existing
footage from all of these characters and
not have to hire anyone just pay them
appearance fees or whatever yes and that
and that movie will make 1 billion
dollars you're still working on the
scrip for loin King right yes loin cake
goes right after poker haunches the
spirit of Deadpool is very much alive in
this episode right now all right I gotta
put an end to this picture Zack you did
a great job especially from Harry Dean
Avengers in game a wonderful film that
probably took itself a bit too seriously
if you ask me and for that you get to
Sparkle buck those turned into I only
own like 14 books but that turned into a
big bowl but it's great hey hey it might
be one of the few improv leaders in this
country to survive this
[Music]
give me these Deadpool theories in a
tweet Hulk killed by Deadpool not cool I
don't like it I wanna see a team-up
between these two dreams oops
Hulk I buy it in bulk
alright Danielle alright here's my tweet
hashtag Deadpool
to the hashtag spider-verse question and
then I would attach a picture of me like
this okay I mine mine is gonna be the in
the style of like a 1950's variety
headline mucho Merc with a mouth
the Murad's into MCU much meta ensues I
love it let us know in the comments
which of these theories for Deadpool you
like the best and want to see the most
in the MCU or if you like all three of
them which order you want to see Kevin
Feige make these movies those of you
watching this know that like now you're
living your entire life online and
you're getting all your content from
different digital streaming platforms
and and now that all of our lives have
to be online it's more important at
least for me than ever to like protect
yourself online protecting your identity
having the kind of access that we all
should have no matter where we are well
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
episode
excerpts APN protects your privacy and
security online but it can also help
unlock movies and shows that are only
available in certain countries like
weirdly Rick and Morty is on Netflix in
France star trek discovery is on Netflix
in the UK you can't watch either of
those shows lots of other shows on just
regular old USA Netflix and those are
you living in the UK or in other
countries probably know that there's
like certain things you can't access
based off where you are well experienced
VPN cuts right through that you just
fire up the expressvpn
app and you change your location refresh
Netflix or Hulu whatever string and
service you're using and you watch
whatever you want regardless of where
you live which is how the Internet
should be exercise a p-n hides your IP
address and lets you control where you
want sites to think you're located and
you can choose from almost a hundred
different countries there are hundreds
of VPNs out there I use Express Swee'Pea
because it is ridiculously fast there's
never any buffering or lag and you can
stream an HD without problems extra
Suqian is compatible with all your
devices phones Media Console smart TVs
and more so you can watch what you want
on a personal device or on the big
screen wherever you are if you visit my
special link right now
expressvpn dot-com / rogue you can get
an extra three months free of expressvpn
support the show watch what you want
protect yourself with expressvpn at
expressvpn comm / rogue okay also every
week those of you on our discord know
that we play a game of rogue theory
specifically with our patrons on new
rockstars official discord this week we
had three selected patrons pitched their
plot for the upcoming the Batman film
with Robert Pattinson directed by Matt
Reeves some really really great ideas
were pitched VIN la and damn wig had
some great theories but the winner was
quiz No well done my friend
quiz no wove Gotham nightclubs and
politics the Riddler the penguin the
Catwoman Harvey Dent all together in a
really fun wire story it's kind of like
LA Confidential but for Batman like
there was a whole mayoral race with
between Thomas Wayne and Oswald
Cobblepot where Thomas Wayne was
assassinated the Naz Wald one but then
was like recalled after a week due to
corruption and then now a Batman 12
years later is like going through the
nightclub scene to try to bring down the
penguin and his revenge story what do
you guys think of this I thought it was
great I'm like a big fan of like
Chinatown and and LA Confidential and
all those kind of like weird twisty Nora
stories and like that's right I really
liked Quiznos seriously she goes like I
don't know we've seen like a Batman
movie that's like such an ensemble piece
was a nightclub that opens up to maybe
some Joel Schumacher neon glow sticks
you know hopped up on Molly drinking
water kissing each other rubbing each
other down you know that's the type of
man I'd love to see it I love the new
are Batman I think that's very and I
feel like it's also very hip right now
to have like
corrupt elections are so and right I
mean you're not wrong look the The Dark
Knight had that ad campaign where like I
support Harvey Dent right they had the
buttons and then like the movie began
with him having already won
but like no at all lead
that whole like meta-narrative that led
into the movie was also super
interesting I would love to see like an
election go down in Gotham all right
speaking of the Batman the director that
movie Matt Reeves did an interview this
week where he was asked if the world
still needed a billionaire Batman now he
said yes but it did get us thinking
about whether Bruce Wayne's insane
wealth is really a necessary part of the
Batman character and if Batman could
work without the billions there have
been some comics stories where Batman
was not rich but every movie version
we've seen from so far he's had
basically unlimited resources which not
saying he you know doesn't deserve it or
he doesn't use it wisely it's just like
is there a version of Batman that's
relatable to us in our financial
struggles I want to hear from you guys
pitch me a Batman movie in which Bruce
Wayne does not get to use his wealth I
have a little bit of a loophole here
every day guy every day Joe living his
life and you know bum Arizona let's put
him in Arizona anyways the lottery
that's relatable or it's like something
that anyone can dream of at least that
much more relatable than like inheriting
though exactly like it's something that
seems more realistic than inheriting
billions of dollars and who wouldn't win
the lottery and then decide to become
Batman I mean a lot of people a lot of
no one has ever done that sure I guess
yeah probably a lot yeah a lot of people
but this guy in this universe he wins
millions he's buys himself up let's say
billions the lottery was up there like
last year right sometimes build up
Batmobile learn some karate skills he's
that man and you don't you don't hate
him for having all that money you know
what's interesting is I've always found
this interesting about the lottery they
have this big event where the person
like reveals themselves like way to put
a target on your back amongst all your
crazy relatives and everyone who went to
grade school at high school with you
they're all gonna be finding you and
like if they know where you live they're
gonna murder you or you're gonna
blackmail you to steal your money don't
if I won I would never out myself I'll
just be like give me the check please
thank you thank you
and I would not let them take pictures
of me with a big check out so this could
be how he was yeah that he's like
alright come at me I'm Batman and he has
to he has to become Batman to protect
himself from all those kids he went to
great school with or whatever yeah
Danielle what was he doing before he won
the lottery like what was he a heroic
person at all or was it just money that
made them decide to be you know some
people might call it a hero but I think
it was a true-crime podcaster you know
already how's it taste yes yeah it
tastes for solving crimes just no skills
or money to do it everyone who listens
to true crime podcasts like deep down
wants to be Batman yeah yes Eric if you
run a million a couple million dollars
wouldn't you secretly become Batman
night by boat exactly see some of us are
from Florida and we've seen people in
Florida win the lottery and they do
become a type of vigilante
it just means they buy a bunch of guns
they get arrested all right I'm gonna
give you another Sparkle buck Rogi for
that theory
better win another one you can go
outside twice right who's next okay
I have I have an idea here so like I my
concept
Batman starts the way we've always seen
in Bruce Wayne as an heir to a fortune
runs a company has a lot of wealth but a
problem arises in Gotham all of the kids
maybe everybody under 16 is falling ill
okay some some kind of crazy you know
it's like a reverse Corona where the
young people are are the ones who are
susceptible and and Bruce Wayne funnels
all of his wealth all of his resources
into trying to find a cure and literally
spent all his money a la a Bill Gates or
whatever who puts a lot of money into
trying to cure diseases and he's he's
like exhausted all of his resources and
he's basically broke but of course it's
like it's his hero ethos right II he has
to save these people
boom of course it comes out is the Joker
started this disease
okay to wipe out kids it's still like no
more laughter disease or whatever okay
and as he's like drained Batman right
Batman comes in like you know beats the
devil out of him
you know Joker's just about to die when
he reveals that like the Cure is in his
blood
or something like that so you have to
keep me alive yeah da da da da but like
we get I I do love the idea of like
Batman with like less money makes him
you said it relatable Eric but also like
it adds stakes like every time he
crashes on the Batmobile he's gonna be
like oh man my insurance premiums but uh
just so you know you don't have to keep
someone alive to keep their blood oh
yeah I don't want to know how you know
that but don't you have to like I know
sometimes to get enough blood to make
enough samples maybe to mass-produce you
have to keep them alive
just gonna keep them in a coma alright
we're learning some dark things about
that's a great way to spend a weekend
little cutie-pie have you been a blood
boy for someone before I both give and
receive blood yes I believe blood is a
full circle it's a circle of life that
moves us all all right Zach for your
theory what I like about your theory is
that say it's dealing with like a public
health crisis which I mean not only is
irrelevant for our current situation but
like most people don't you know really
feel the consequences of their financial
hardship until there's some kind of
illness or injury that realized oh I'm
not protected all I don't have insurance
so like more people go bankrupt from
like not being able to pay their health
care or having some kind of illness than
anything else so that's what I think is
super interesting to go the health angle
so for that I'm gonna give you another
Sparkle
that became a storyteller the roald dahl
biography Wow
I know I haven't I'm like 10 pages in I
probably always will be alright Tommy
what's your Batman theory okay so my
theory is it's a quiet time in Gotham so
Bruce Wayne is actually taking more of a
visual role at Wayne Enterprises and
also still selling the image of himself
as billionaire playboy obnoxious
alcoholic reckless his behavior begins
to disenfranchise a young accountant at
Wayne Enterprises who is a master of
math and statistics and probability a
young Nathan Silver if you will
he deduces that Bruce Wayne is Batman
without any be out like he figures out
he figures out with an equation I love
Mark Zuckerberg at the window and in
social network that that makes it
irresistible ik with that information
unless Bruce Wayne liquidates through
bad investments his fortune now this man
is he's more of a like altruistic not
altruistic but like a he he's an
eco-terrorist he doesn't want anything
for his own gain he wants to see a
billionaire fall to his knees so he
forces Matt Bruce Wayne to make a series
of bad investments that he's also
figured out through probability kind of
like the computer and Westworld this
season that can kind of predict the
market and actually control the market
you're kind of using technology similar
to that to to convince art to figure out
what how Bruce we can make these
investments and basically sink the
company drive them out of business so
that happens we cut to five years later
Bruce Wayne is now brought a broken man
he has nothing he has some physical
assets left he has no liquid cash he is
literally solving crimes in the joke
manner mentioned in The Dark Knight he's
wearing hockey pads as he is fighting
like he is what I know it sounds funny
but I mean literally he has to figure
out a way to still continue to
serve this this this duty he feels he
has to the city to save the people of
Gotham with with meager limited
resources and the help of you know the
people that were once below him and
dedicated servants and you know like
Lucius Fox and Alfred are now actually
more wealthy than him and they can only
help so much you know the way that if
you have a relative who's you know
wealthy but not rich they can send you
$50 for your birthday but they can't pay
for your college you know so so it's
basically a a story of of a man who's
lost at all trying to find the rich that
comes within the satisfaction of the
carcase work stock markets aren't going
so well for you right now
cashed out three years early for pennies
on the dollar Tommy you know you kind of
bring up that subplot and in the Dark
Knight Rises you know where Bane was
kind of this Dickensian class warrior
where he he hit a Bruce Wayne that is it
is stock value or whatever and the way
he hit him in that movie makes no sense
in the real world like he would have
certain like protections right someone
tried to like form a heist and Wall
Street yeah so you can't hit someone
that way but to like a long you know
death by a thousand cuts forcing him to
make bad investments and slowly just you
found like a good rewrite of that weird
bane subplot and Dark Knight Rises I
think that's kind of what the seed for
that idea was just like what have we
made that a little more plausible so
this guy's less of a Robin Hood and more
of just like wants to see the world burn
yeah he's a joker almost maybe he is the
Joker maybe he's the son of the Joker
maybe he's judged it baby's the daughter
of the Joker Wow
[Laughter]
but I will live in Ron
the rewarding of a sparkle Rogi but
strange music box of mice around us on
the scene I found can you hear it
like oh we can hear it I'll hear it
through my dream job we're definitely
all cursed they're working hard and does
that make any money these mice are our
slaves do they come to life at nighttime
they come to life all right give it back
to me a tweet yeah rags to riches Batman
Batman wins the lottery uses it to buy a
Batmobile in stuff the end you know to
save on characters hashtag everyman and
then use the emoji the dollar sign and
then the winky face i I love that to eat
because I feel like out of context
people would be like wait Batman
everyman like everyone on Twitter would
be like tell them my 36 followers I'm
very good at Twitter we'll get you more
from this episode yes okay so my tweet
would be Wow Batman bleeds himself try
to save Gotham's kids in the end he has
to bleed Joker dry hashtag Batman
hashtag hashtag 2024 all right Tommy
Bruce Wayne broke that's a joke unless
it's not it's all part of an evil plot
from a new accountant reaching into the
fountain of Bruce Wayne's riches and
that's all [ __ ] I guess it rhymes if
you make up worth like fountain and I do
all right now we have time for a few
rogue questions are you guys ready yes
twitter user dinosaur Dracula got a lot
of attention last week when he opened up
a twenty five year old can of spider-man
chef boyardee and it had turned into a
dusty brick oh I love this what food
from your childhood would you risk
certain debts to try again
I'll start I was a huge fan of surge
Cola as a tween and I'm sure there are
parts of me that will never be the same
because of how much surge Cola I drank
it was like it was pitched is like a
more a hardcore mountain dew and this
this little dude really enjoyed it my
might be dunkaroos yeah you know those
would never go bad either I could crack
open one of those babies the icing would
still be smooth for me I went to rehab
for fun dip the foot into the dust I was
free base of that and I would chase it
with Joel Cola and I don't know if you
remember but Joe colas Bragg was that
they had 10 times the caffeine of
regular Cola it's crazy that I've
struggled with uppers my whole life if
you think about it fun dip is kind of
like the ultimate gateway drug yeah we
weren't even kids
powders yeah early but if he ever
snorted God does it hurt so I don't just
eat it normal if you find a fun dip just
eat it you eat it normally off of the
sweet tart shaped like a foot okay any
other eat it normally boil it we know
how to eat fun dip next question this
week was April 20th 4/20 what who's your
favorite pop-culture character that
isn't publicly a STONER but is
definitely a STONER Daniel Tiger Daniel
Tiger
Daniel Tiger's Playhouse he doesn't have
a job he lives in a tree house
he speaks in kind of a hepcat language
where he replaces regular words with
meows I mean he's been around since the
70s so I mean it was like be like the
same way Bart Simpson is 11 or 10 Daniel
Tiger is probably 195 for all we know
and he's getting lifted up in that tree
okay I think mine is definitely
Michelangelo of the ninja of the Ninja
Turtle variety because he's like it's
not the painter but also probably the
painter yeah he's like I mean they all
love pizza but he loves lots of snacks
and he's just so goofy even in stressful
fighting situations he's just making up
goofs and not really paying attention
and he always is the one that comes up
with the wrong catchphrase word you know
they're like to be like excellent and
then he says some random oh yeah that's
that's the mind of a STONER sort of
that's a theme see both Daniel and I
agree stoners make up words that don't
exist
yeah well in keeping with that theme my
pick is gonna be Groot okay
from the guardians of the galaxy cuz not
only I mean he is a plant right so you
we don't know his exact cell structure
there could be some cannaboids THC CBD
flowing through we know like he kind of
can shoot off like little things that
look like embers as if maybe he's almost
smoking himself I mean you know that
tree smokes trees come on yes yes and
he's like that kind of stone where you
only can say like the one thing over and
over again yeah yeah yeah for
Michelangelo Daniel I give you one of
these because I believe that you have to
be stoned to eat pizza that is clearly
that hot and melty and not really react
true yeah alright and final question
tiger king finally got bumped from the
top of Netflix's top ten for the first
time in a month by despicable me so I
want you guys to give me your best
impression of Joe exotic threatening the
minion minion you see you can come over
here
let me tell you something Stuart when
you watch pornos do you like the little
bitty piece or now you listen here you
little yellow turd looking tiny banana
eaters Karma's a [ __ ] and so are the
explosives that got in the back of my
[Laughter]
right we might need to edit mine in
first cuz it'll be the weakest follow
these people okay so mine's gonna be
like hey use the one with the one on
okay did you just like Carol by skin
alright and I know you killed your
minion wife okay buried her on your
property okay and then he shoots a gun
indoors okay I'm going to award all
three of you a Rogi
mine came back is this scary football
player Ghostbuster Micheal Chabon
Moonglow another book I never okay so
let's go good enough to get enough
rookies no no you then next time maybe
[Laughter]
okay let's look at how much rogue ease
do we have let's break it down I 3 I 4
ok I have 4 as well whoa oh ok
so whoever can do the best minion
response to Joe exotic gets the win
banana
alright so Daniel do you have a wish
something that you can force your co
contestants to do as is your winning
privilege I wish that they would do a
cover of one of Joe exotics songs from
the top three to one diagur
Tiger song man Tiger fan I do whatever a
tiger can I eat little baby because
that's it yes well done well that is it
for this episode of rogue theory thanks
to our guests
Tommy and Danielle and Zak you all three
of you were wonderful give yourselves a
round of applause
Jagger and Phillips should be back next
week this is not a permanent thing he's
so much better at this than I am I'm
happy just to get back to my other toy
aleem that I normally do don't forget to
subscribe to the rogue theory podcast
feed and stay tuned to the YouTube
channel for this and plenty of other
shows you can follow me on twitter at EI
vas and of course follow me rock stars
trying to get that crazy nightmare music
out of your head and we'll see you next
week bye guys
[Music]